the new freedom rankings out every year
researchers at the Fraser and Cato
Institute's compare economic freedoms
like the freedom to trade amount of
regulations tax levels plus personal
freedoms like women's rights and
religious freedom they published the
results in the human freedom index it
compares countries according to how free
they are so is America the freest
country no we came in 17th this year
well behind many other countries the
report says the freest countries are now
Switzerland Hong Kong New Zealand
Ireland and then Australia years ago
America was near the top of the economic
freedom list the United States used to
have one of the freest economies in the
world
Ian Vasquez helped write the ranking it
used to be two three or four and then
government started to grow its third to
spend more to step in with dramatic
government action and regulate war these
strongest consumer financial protections
in history and tax for those who are
more fortunate or gonna have to pay a
little bit more those are reasons we
fell on the freedom list so let's look
at the top of the list
why does Switzerland rank first in the
world because it has comparatively
little regulation low taxes a free press
and other freedoms like same-sex
marriage that many other countries lack
a good ranking matters not just because
it's good to be free but because freedom
allows people to prosper look what
happened in Hong Kong number 2 on the
list Hong Kong a thousand words in this
one small spot not long ago people in
Hong Kong were among the poorest in the
world but now they're among the richest
what do I like about Hong Kong
every moment there's something exciting
going on prosperity happened because
Hong Kong's government put few obstacles
in the way of trying new things like
starting a business Here I am in Hong
Kong years ago applying for legal
permission to open a business handing in
one form was all I had to do Thank You
chef
the next morning I opened Stossel
enterprises it was a stupid business
selling things like American frisbees
but that chance to try new things is
what allowed Hong Kong to prosper by
comparison India ranks much lower
because there to start a business
entrepreneurs may have to wait years
while bureaucrats like these debate the
merit of your idea good ideas die
waiting on these shelves that's a reason
India stays poor it could be worse the
most oppressed people in the world of
those who live in the countries at the
bottom of the freedom ranking Egypt
Yemen Libya Venezuela and least free
Syria mostly because of the war
you aren't free if you worry about being
killed second least free country
Venezuela was once the richest country
in Latin America then socialists
promised they'd spread the wealth
now Venezuelans fight over bags of flour
freedom is under attack all around the
world
Tania porchdick is the rankings other
author I interviewed her by Skype
because she now lives in Austria though
she was born in Slovakia you moved to
Austria to get more freedom yes freedom
just inspired me freedom relates to
other things that matter what's
important in life
those of us who revere freedom often say
it's the dignity of the individual and a
chance to live free from coercion you
can leave your life any way you want as
long as you respect the equal rights of
others
what job you want to take what kinds of
things you want to do who you want to
marry what you want to do on your free
time where you want to live countries
don't regulate your free time oh yes
they do they regulate everything they
regulate vacation time where you can
travel if you're a woman in some parts
over the world you have to ask
permission for men to go out in public
freedom brings good things to countries
that try out you feeling people now want
to live at third ranked New Zealand the
country is politically and economically
stable of people all over the world
attracted by the benefits and
opportunities Ireland used to be poor
but now it ranks fourth on the freedom
index
you don't just arrived in Ireland you
jump in Ireland I think about the potato
famine
I don't think about prosperity they
reduced taxes they reduced spending they
reduced some regulations they opened up
to trade crackdown on China's trade
abuses America now may close itself to
some tre if that makes you want to move
to another country the rankings offer
places to consider and places to avoid
[Music]
Greece is beautiful but it ranks 60th
and freedom China has gotten richer but
it ranks 130th you could read the full
rankings on the Cato Institute's and
Frazier Institute's websites it's too
bad that the u.s. is now only 17th in
the rankings but the good news is that
we are 17th partly because in recent
years other countries became more free
despite what we hear on the news over
several decades the world has slowly
been getting better
you